this podcast has bad words
how do you live as a minimalist with a
hoarder my boyfriend is the worst
accumulator of crap i've ever seen
there's some something much deeper going
on than hoarding here
our house is littered with the remains
of all the hobbies he tried to start
every time amazon every time amazon
comes i groan
all right well let's let's talk about
this so
there could be a compatibility issue
here and relationships are sort of three
things that are the glue of any
relationship there is
chemistry that's how relationships often
start right
you can even think of these as sort of
like the head the heart and the
genitalia
[Music]
so i look at everything
and and with
the chemistry obviously it's like i'm
i'm attracted to you
now that can be sexual attraction but it
can also just be there are certain
people who are magnetic right
and so it doesn't have to be a sexual
attraction there's a chemistry
between the dynamic of two different
people right yes the chemistry you
notice right away so this is the
genitals we're talking about
we're talking about your genitals ryan
i'm sorry
i don't mean to derail you all right
continue yes so we're talking about
chemistry and we often mistake that
chemistry as what oh compatibility right
that's the second component right yes
now that is the head the compatibility
do we have the same interest do we have
the same
once the the the desires the hobbies
same values yeah the same values the
same preferences right where do how do
we align in those areas right mm-hmm and
then there's a third one and it's love
that's the heart right and that's seeing
things for how they are without trying
to change them
and so
i hate to inform you but if you hope to
change him
then you're lacking the love component
as well
now i understand the desire to want to
change someone well where does that come
from it comes from a particular sort of
self-righteousness yeah right and we all
experience some sort of
self-righteousness some some of us
experience different from others yeah we
were talking about the enneagram
recently but ryan you are a seven when a
seven gets stressed he turns into a one
which is the perfectionist which is a
really nice way to say the
self-righteous person
which is really a way if we take out the
take that out and it turns into binary
thinking yeah is really the way to look
at that yeah and and so because you're
the enthusiast you don't have the you
don't typically have the binary thinking
you it's the imbibing on life it's the
the happy-go-lucky seven right yeah but
when you get stressed it's
right and wrong black and white yes or
no yeah but life doesn't work that way
right
and so
it's not that you're a minimalist and
he's a hoarder and then now you're going
to make him a minimalist or he's going
to make you a hoarder or you're going to
be discontented no
if you're lacking compatibility
then you're probably going to be
discontented does that mean i'm telling
you to break up with your boyfriend
no
but
the problem here is that you hope to
convince him
that he should behave otherwise you're
helping
her
see it for what it is yes there is no
right or wrong here it's it's a matter
of like you live with someone who is a
hoarder
and you have a choice you can either
uh love them
and really it makes me think of the
terror acronym right you tolerate you
you
accept
you respect and then you even get to a
point of appreciation and i think when
you truly love someone you get to that
point of appreciation
now i'm trying to put myself in her
shoes like let's say mariah started to
be a hoarder yes i actually love mariah
so much i would be like okay we have to
live in separate i'll still
be your husband and we can still be
romantic partners but we will have to
live in separate houses and i mean
that's what it would eventually but i
would but that would actually be in a
weird way supporting her of being like
hey i think that you should have
whatever horde you want to have um but
unfortunately like i cannot live
in in a hoarder's house yeah so is this
is this mean you go to your boyfriend
and you tell them hey i can't live in no
that's not it at all i'm just taking it
kind of to the extreme here i'm trying
to put myself in your shoes but you can
certainly go to your boyfriend
and say hey like i really
love you i want to i want to support you
as much as i can
and uh i'm trying to do that but i also
need some support as well and that's
really how
that's the best way to gain support and
to gain respect from your partner you
have to go out of your way
to respect and to support your partner
if you're not doing anything to respect
or support them then of course they're
not going to want to reciprocate at all
yeah and i think where we get into
trouble is when we accidentally place
ourselves on that pedestal right and so
when i
when i read the question my boyfriend is
the worst accumulator of crap i've ever
seen yeah okay maybe he's the best
accumulator of crap you've ever seen
just imagining like piles of [ __ ] in all
the rooms
at stage five right that is stage five
boarding and and so
yes we we've talked during this whole
maximum episode we've talked about
spartanism obsessive compulsive
decluttering but the other side of that
is the obsessive compulsive
hoarding
and so yes maybe he has some sort of
ocd like i have
and it is manifesting by the holding on
to items right
now can you help him see the truth
yes without having to convince him you
can help him see the truth what is the
truth the externalities are not going to
make you more complete they're not going
to make you happier they're not going to
make you more joyous at best your
material possessions can enhance your
life or amplify your life at the very
best how
because each item
has some sort of
serve some sort of purpose it adds value
to your life in some way
but if you're hoarding if you're truly a
hoarder most of your things virtually
all of your things are the opposite of
that yeah they're not adding value so
maybe
and maybe your boyfriend is actually
getting value from these things maybe
he's a bit of a maximalist and not a
hoarder and if he's getting value from
those things then you have a fundamental
compatibility issue that doesn't mean
that you should break up with him it
means understanding the breakdown
incompatibility and if you expect him to
change or he expects you to change
you're both going to get dragged in that
direction until you realize that's not
going to be possible man it makes me
think and i'm not saying that this is
the case here with anne but
it just makes me think of how
there are relationships i stayed in
where there wasn't compatibility and i
stayed in it because
well for a lot of reasons like a um i
didn't want to fail right
um
i didn't think i could do any better
i
it was convenient that's probably the
number one thing is it was convenient to
stay with that person
and uh yeah i just i'm not again i'm not
saying this is the problem with him but
for myself it was like
i don't know man like just you have to
come to realization of like
do i am i okay staying in this
relationship that i feel is
i'm trying not to say mediocre but i
can't think of another word but that's
what i would do you say it's making me
miserable right exactly yeah am i okay
to stay in this relationship that's
making me miserable
um
if the answer is yes then great stay in
the relationship so be it yeah so be it
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent advertisement free